I'm a big fan of matcha green tea I
drink it on a daily basis and you know
what you can also add much into your
food if you have not heard or tried
matcha seriously you're missing out
matcha is the highest quality powdered
green tea it is thought away from light
and oxygen in order to preserve its
bright vivid green color and also
antioxidant properties it has been
consumed for over thousands of years in
the Far East but now it is a big hype
among the fitness community so much' is
essentially finely powdered green tea
which is mixed into water and consumed
whole unlike regular green tea when you
consume much up you're consuming the
entire Crush tea leaf instead of just
live infused water so here this guys
when you consume 1 cup of matcha green
tea you're getting the benefits of 10
cups of a regular green tea so some of
the new benefits include its high
antioxidant properties it has 5 times
more antioxidants than goji berries it
also helps to remove toxins from the
body it has a calming effect and it will
help to keep you looking young guys I
hope I've convinced you to consume
matcha
so here are 4 really simple and healthy
matchup breakfast recipes let's start
with matcha oatmeal pancakes what you'll
need are 1 cup of oat flour 1 cup of any
milk of your choice 1 large banana one
part of chair mixture which is a
combination of 1 tablespoon of chia
seeds 2 3 tablespoons of water 1
tablespoon of matcha powder 1/2 a
tablespoon of maple syrup and 1 teaspoon
of baking soda
roughly mash the banana in a bowl then
add in the milk
Chesson mixture and maple syrup mix
until well combined then add in the dry
ingredients oat flour matcha and baking
soda keep mixing until you get a consist
better scoop about quarter cup of the
batter and cook on a non-stick pan over
medium heat once your pancake starts to
bubble flip it and cook for another 1 to
2 minutes
don't press it the pancakes alright you
want to keep them nice and fluffy so I
got a little too excited and decided to
build a huge stack of pancakes
I laid mine with sliced bananas top it
up with Greek yogurt and strawberry
drizzled with a little bit of maple
syrup and dusted off with more mature
just look at this epic breakfast each
pancake has about of 56 calories so the
combination of oats and bananas will
keep you full make this breakfast and be
sure to share it alright the next recipe
is much coconut granola so what I've
used are 1 tablespoon of matcha powder 1
cup of rolled oats 1/2 a cup of mixed
nuts and seeds I've used macadamias
sunflower seeds and cashew nuts half a
cup of mixed dried fruits I've used goji
berries and cranberries 2 tablespoons of
desiccated coconut 2 tablespoons of
coconut oil 2 tablespoons of maple syrup
and a pinch of salt preheat the oven to
150 degrees Celsius in a baking tray
stir in the rolled oats mixed nuts and
seeds desiccated coconut matcha
and a pinch of salt mix all the
ingredients together then stir in the
wet ingredients maple syrup and coconut
oil mix until all the ingredients are
evenly coated transfer the mixture onto
a lined baking tray and spread it out
evenly bake in the oven for a total of
30 minutes notice that we haven't added
the dried fruits because we don't want
them to burn so when it's about 20
minutes mix in the dried fruits and
gently flip the granola bake for the
remaining 10 minutes remove and allow it
to cool down
you can choose to dust it off with more
shapow damn and transfer into an
airtight jar so each quarter cup serving
has about 130 calories this granola can
be served over milk or yogurt you can
have it on its own or top it up onto
chia pudding which is my next recipe
much a chia pudding what you'll need are
quarter cup of chia seeds 3/4 cup of any
milk of your choice one teaspoon of
maple syrup or honey 2 teaspoons of
matcha green-tea
and two small jars this recipe is really
simple simply combine chia seeds milk
maple syrup and matcha powder stir well
divide equally into two small jars cover
and allow it to set overnight in the
fridge
the next morning ill expand into a
pudding like texture
I've topped mine up with some homemade
granola so each jar topped with quarter
cup of granola has about 323 calories so
what I love about this recipe is that
it's really convenient on a busy day I
can just grab a jar and have it on a go
so prep ahead and it will keep well in
the fridge for up to four days the final
recipe is perfect as a snack no bake
matcha macaroons
what you need are half a cup of
desiccated coconut 1 tablespoon of
matcha powder 3 tablespoons of sesame
seeds 2 tablespoons of coconut oil 2
tablespoons of peanut butter quarter cup
of maple syrup one teaspoon of vanilla
extract and a pinch of salt mix together
all the dry ingredients desiccated
coconut sesame seeds matcha and a pinch
of salt combined well then stir in the
wet ingredients
coconut oil maple syrup peanut butter
and vanilla extract combine until it
forms a consistent paste take about 1
tablespoon of the mixture and roll into
a ball don't worry if they dough
look perfect this will make about a
night to 12 balls and dusted off with
more mature a lot of macaroons to set in
the fridge for about one hour or until
solid I've dusted mine with more
desiccated coconut this ball is packed
with nutrients and it will give you
energy to power you through your day so
each ball has about 100 calories
you can have 2 to 3 balls for breakfast
or as a healthy snack here are few
really important tips when it comes to
consuming my child so you want to
consume between half a teaspoon to two
teaspoons a day although matcha it's low
in caffeine
it still has caffeine so you want to
avoid consuming matcha in the evening
and you want to only consume matcha with
either water or low protein milk so
never consume much out with dairy milk
because it will only destroy all the
benefits and nutrients good quality
matcha is bright vivid green and has a
fine powdery texture avoid anything that
is yellow in color of course it won't
taste good and typically good quality
matcha comes from Japan remember all
these tips so be sure to try all these
recipes make them for breakfast and let
me know which is your favorite in the
comments below don't forget to tag me at
Jonas or official and hashtag j-serve
recipes like this video share this video
and subscribe to my youtube channel for
a lot more healthy recipes workout
videos and also fitness tips do you also
turn on your notification button so that
you will get notified every time I share
a new video all the best